hi my name is Kathleen I'm from San Jose
California hi Kathleen hi um my question
is has there ever been a twist that was
a runner-up idea on the story board but
never came into fruition oh yeah hi-oh
whole bunch of like the first draft of
all the yeah um all the time but you
want to hear one just does one come to
mind all right I'm trying I'm actually
trying to think of a think of one that
we definitely wouldn't do we kicked
around the idea of Malcolm being my dad
right that was that was an early
conversation and then we realized that
was a little that was a little too Darth
Vader there's a little to access your
husband it was over lunch with Andrew
Kreisberg that we Scott was eating a
Caesar salad and Andrew said you guys
were discussing that and said it to me
and I went in Scotland know to Darth is
like what you're saying it's a Darth
Vader why don't you make a Willa
your daughter Thea way it was Scott it
was the idea oh my god it is thank you
Scott totally so thank you yeah I mean
aside from the fact that you would have
had to have had me when you were 10 yeah
I love you even more thank you very much
because I've done the math and I could
have had you at an early age ha ha ha
well played well played thank you thank
you
yeah love your t-shirt thank you um my
name is Sophie I from Henderson Nevada
if you were to play a character on
Marvel regardless of gender would you
play in Y nice
the brave oh that's a good one your
record show I did not ask that question
Eko um one of my favourite Marvel
characters is Apocalypse and he's a bad
guy but I just loved all his powers they
can like grow and like morph and
transform I would definitely apocalypse
hmm um I'm so comic-book illiterate it's
embarrassing I'm on this DC show and I
don't even know which one's DC and which
ones Marvel people talk about Easter
eggs and stuff I'm like what you mean
like an easter egg they're like no no no
Easter eggs oh I don't get it
I couldn't you in years answer that
question but I'm sure Emily could I'll
take them for the team hey I'll be
Wolverine be great Wolverine that much
you took the word right out of my mouth
I was gonna see how Vereen high will
chair we could do I was literally gonna
say Wolverine because it's an awesome
character sorry agent Carter I'm
fighting I'd be agent Carter I was so
waving like no one's interested in
sucking up to me at all on this cat I'd
be agent thank you miss your walk - I
guess because Emily took Wolverine and
Ed we'd storm cuz her hair was pretty
good yeah yeah there's I used to love a
cat named moon night agent Carter but if
moon I was tossing but if I is really a
cross between Moon Knight and Jean Grey
during the Dark Phoenix saga
so job story that was the that was the
opposite of Paul's answer yeah that was
pretty nobody could have half moon that
I could give me a moon I that was that
was impressive I was impressed there
moon night was awesome
teach me something that's awesome yeah
thank you hello thank you so much hi hi
I am Raj and I'm from San Jose
California and I'm really excited to see
you guys today especially especially
Emily so
hahaha so one question is what special
skills that you guys have to learn for
your own I know Stefan probably learn ok
I'm disgusting
haha exam but I have to learn I mean
obviously you grew came out of the womb
knowing the Salmon Ladder like anyone
else
I mean you are other skills that you
have to figure out archery yeah uh you
know yeah I think Steven and I and John
have all had to pick up a bow a few
times and know how to hold it properly
yeah I think we've all had to have our
moments of fight training and working
with you know on-screen combat and
understanding how that best works I know
that echo has been getting a good
education in that this year and uh walk
yeah heals yeah walking in heels which I
did yesterday time don't spoil it
don't spoil it oh gosh Oliver doesn't
walk in heels on the show but Stephen
Amell does I do and we love him for that
even more what he does for his free time
in the mayor office yeah and also we
some of us we've had to work with I know
we'll and I've done stuff with and the
others have done stuff with the swords
and you know that one of the thing and
I'm going to get it wrong but please
help me the-the-the-the Japanese the
outfit that what's the katana for me
that was very difficult to learn how to
do stuff in because you're not you're
not support it's talk told to you that
you're supposed to move in it like
you're on wheels so it doesn't go up and
down and I'm I'm from the dance world
where it's you know tap dancing is up
and down so they were used to keep just
coming up and going stop bouncing
keep it level and that was difficult so
yeah Malcolm would always throw punches
and then John would put a little
flourish yeah ha ha and James Bamford
who's directing our first and second
episodes would be like John stop it ha
ha ha just hit him don't don't close
your bit close your fist yeah breathe
make sure to breathe yeah ha ha this is
not a chorus line stop it thank you
thanks man thank you hi hi I'm Valentina
from Argentina and my question was if
you would change your character which
one would you change for like which
character would you want to be on the
show yeah I would want to be uh wait now
I take that back so I'm gonna I'm gonna
say I'd like to be diggable for everyone
else says they'd like to be Diggle ha ha
ha
I'd be Malcolm I'd be Oliver I'd be
Malcolm - Malcolm really yo yeah Oh so
since everyone else is wearing pumps I
wouldn't mind being felicity Smoak's
lucky yeah so our team humps I mean
that's what I was gonna say but then I
realized right before I said that that
that would also include somewhat of an
incestual relationship with my brother
and then I had to take that back uh but
yeah obviously I would want to be Emily
but like Emily the person everybody
tails I get headaches so I can't do that
much gamma sod your head for you huh
I'll massage your head for you Oh cute
cute what about you echo um yeah Diggle
oh yeah they're easy easy one
okay that's racist it's not racist I
didn't pick the black ah I like their go
especially and I like this black that's
cool too thank you thank you very often
for sure okay and how awesome she's
margin Tina oh yeah yes a racist
pleasure hi how are you hi I'm Liz I'm
from Tijuana Mexico and I wanted to know
who was your favorite superhero growing
up and will you play that character
nowadays because I am that man
cool sorry that's just all I couldn't
know about that
Sailor Moon and absolutely freaking
lutely Sailor man saleable Salem Ash
Ketchum right yeah a sketch um yeah
Pokemon let's go by the way download
Pokemon go it's so much fun don't fall
in rivers the new game I'm not gonna
it's gonna it's it again yeah uh John
McLean oh and by the way I don't think
that movies should be rebooted unless
they want to reboot it and let me play
it uh by the way none of these people
we've said our superhero how dare you
wait John McClane a hero of his story
echo every one of us our story on five
movies show me an order three of which
that's really good as a race
um it's an easy answer for me as a kid
when I came from Scotland to the u.s.
playing in the basement with the Mego
action figures Captain America
definitely nice oh yeah right yeah we
will be Bruce Banner not the hope but
Bruce Banner yeah yeah or Mark Ruffalo
sorry what's rolling would you would you
be Mark Ruffalo I think Mark Ruffalo was
the best banner I saw totally yeah oh
okay sorry did that game thank you
something to my cousin every second
boo-ki oh hi hi my name is Becca I'm
from Los Altos California and I was just
wondering what aspects of yourselves do
you see in your characters and
vice-versa
you know I used to actually work at Geek
Squad at Best Buy for like four years so
that like Wendy did this quote was like
if Felicity is a software Kurtis is the
hardware and I was like the hardware
dude at geek squad so I really feel like
I connect with Kurtis on a lot of those
tech levels oh she would go down the
line okay right okay um quit and I gosh
I hope not too much in to be honest this
is a nightmare being Quentin Lance you
know your daughters dying bawling your
eyes out it's drinking it's terrible
pretty yeah so I say that with you know
I mean it's wonderful being Quentin
Lance I say that as well it's just um
should I just stop talking baby he's got
some dark side isn't he maybe I've got
some dark sides too but listen I'll talk
about that what about you Emily
oh I always started working like
Felicity talks to herself and I think
that's just because I do this she's
always just like me
and then so yeah that would be
characteristic I'm I'm stubborn and I'm
prideful and I hold grudges and I'm not
a murderer
ah but I'm a little bit more like Oliver
than maybe I'm prepared to admit yeah I
think John diggle's sense of a family I
think we both share that not nearly as
good as he is but his sense of love for
his family his child and wants to make a
better word about a place forest child I
think that we both share that uh I mean
back in the days she used to go there a
lot so I feel like I had a lot of it in
common but eating burgers it especially
a big belly burger whatever is my number
one thing of it yeah I love burgers yeah
that's all I got guys um I am Oh
I'm not mean I'm not manipulative but I
am like Malcolm in the way that I am
loyal and I'm committed and that's
probably the only relic I don't have a
you also usually refer to yourself as
the hero of your own story when I met
you for the first time you said hi
Steven my name is John Barrowman I am
the hero of my own story a lot like
Malcolm then okay good question thank
you thank you and I believe this is
gonna be our last question
oh I don't make the rules hi um I was
just wondering if we're gonna see any
Bruce Wayne soon on arrow
oh that not Batman Bruce Wayne um no
it's a show called Gotham you're
probably gonna like a lot yeah I
recommend it to you but I I would I
would say and I think that you would
agree with this that you would never say
never oh I would never say never like
any time that I say never I usually end
up doing what I say I'm never gonna do
almost immediately well in that case in
that case I want to say that Bruce will
never be on morrow yeah because I want
Bruce to be on arrow there we go
I like
you